foreign
Portland Oregon hi Sierra welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello thanks for having me sure what's
up um we just completed baby steps two
through four and we have approached baby
steps five but my husband and I have a
disagreement
um when it comes to saving for your kids
college fund um I'm all for it and my
husband is against it
against
saving for your kids yes he does not
think he should pay for his kids college
or anything having to do with it
correct how come
uh so we both went to college got our
bachelor's degree my husband about four
years ago ended his career and switched
into a trade
um the trade by far in two years he was
making what he was making doing his
college career job and
he thinks that
college is like a waste of money now
that he's been in a trade and he also
believes that my son or our son I should
say sorry
um will appreciate money more which I
disagree if he has to pay for himself so
um and also in addition
I don't know how long it will be but the
union has started a program where they
pay 100 of the college but the degree
options are limited at this point so
there's that kind of ball in the court
too as well
foreign
well I paid for all three of my
children's college education and it had
nothing to do uh that did not cause them
to not have an appreciation for the
dollar all three of them understand work
ethic all three of them understand the
value of a dollar and so your husband's
full of crap
on that subject
I have proof otherwise
now I understand because I come from the
same
I'm cut out the same cloth he's cut out
of he believes in hard work he believes
in earning your way and he believes it's
good for your kid to build those muscles
of self-reliance and uh Destiny and uh
control you know I I agree with all that
and I've got a friend who's a NFL
football player uh ex-nfl football
player who uh grew up blue collar dad
there was a dock worker and his dad said
they're not paying for nothing he went
to school on a scholarship playing
football and then went on into the NFL
and he refused to in the NFL making NFL
money to save anything for his kids
college so uh but uh the idea that the
only way your child learns the value of
a dollar is to make sure they have no
dollars is bullcrap
okay but they but but I do understand
his line of thinking so I don't disagree
with I understand how he got there he's
just wrong okay so you can teach a kid
the value of a dollar you can teach them
hard work even if they come from a
family of means even if they come where
they have a college fund
um and uh you can actually hold it over
their head make sure that they learn
these things you know
um uh and the other thing I would just
say is the other place I I and I do
agree with him that the trades are
oftentimes a better option than a stupid
but degree that is nuanced and has
absolutely no application in the real
world I'm going to get a degree in
German polka history and left-handed
puppetry and then [ __ ] and moan because
Society owes me something while I'm a
barista that's just dumb okay and that
happens all the time out there and I
don't I agree with him that we're not
going to salute that stupidity either
but to say that all kids don't need a
four-year education is ludicrous it's
nonsense so let me let me tell you this
um my grandmother my grandma smoked when
she was younger
she when she passed away she did not
pass away from lung cancer
that doesn't mean that lung cancer
doesn't give you or smoking doesn't give
you cancer I think we've proven
equivocally that that smoking increases
cancer rates exponentially
just because your husband got a
four-year degree and has found more
success in a trade
doesn't mean that all people who get
four years degrees are dumber than
people who get go to trades it's just
not how it works I nor does it mean the
opposite what I mean the opposite that
if you're if you get a go to a trade and
don't go get a four-year degree you're
dumb right because there's some people
need to do that too we need people on
the trades we need people with this but
but to not have a money allocated to
cause the future success of your child
whether it's a certification as a diesel
mechanic or and pay for that or whether
it's a four-year degree in business and
pay for that uh you're giving your kids
options when you do that when you have
no money set aside you took away a lot
of the options that's right and I will
I've got several friends who had
assistance with with financial
assistance my family was in a position
to do that and I will tell you we are
the same age and we all equally work
really hard
and the their ability to do some things
early on when it came to investing when
it came to home buying that I wasn't
able to do has accelerated their wealth
building because they had options and so
I'm like Dave I my kids will know how to
work hard they will know how to how to
grind and hustle and what a dollar means
and Lord willing if I'm able to help
them pay for their college education or
their trades I'm gonna I'm gonna make
every effort possible to make that
happen yeah and so here's the thing 100
of the humans out there unless they have
a a a a mental disability
need some kind of education post High
School
to be financially successful it's not a
hundred percent necessary but it's 98
necessary you really don't take a single
thing After High School you are behind
the curve and so you need to go get
certifications in Microsoft and go into
technology at the local community
college or Tech College that's fine
that's going into a trade you go be a
diesel mechanic that's fine be a welder
that's fine get your real estate license
get your real estate license that's fine
but continuing education throughout your
life
is the path of successful people we have
people that come in here they're 40
years old and applying for a leadership
role in there and I ask them what book
they've read and they can't remember one
well that disqualify
you know you don't get to come in here
and be a leader you're not learning
anything new you always are learning and
so you always want to encourage learning
is a is a continual process we love
books we love reading we love learning
uh but we re and we respect your ability
to go into the military we respect your
ability to go into a trade we respect
and and those are fine career paths and
we've and the higher education
communities look down their nose at them
for too long so I agree with lifting
those up micro is a good friend of mine
we're in agreement about that dirty jobs
guy you know and so uh he's got a whole
movement on the trades thing and but
he's not against College he's got a
degree you know and this is Mr dirty
jobs for God's sakes you know and so uh
you know all of that to say uh I
understand completely and agree with why
your husband is saying what he's saying
but I think he's taking the wrong track
absolutely yeah I think you I think you
put the money aside money for future
learning will never go to waste exactly
it's all it's always the best build a
culture in your house of hard work and
future learning that's right you know
you're always going to be learning
you're always going to be reading you're
always going to be learning you're
always going to be reading I was telling
the story of our team yesterday we've
adopted a school here at Ramsey that was
my old elementary school and we were
able to go in several years ago and
rebuild the library and uh in the name
of in the honor of my old principal in
out of our family Foundation now our
company is adopting this and coming
around these 83 teachers and trying to
help them because he's poor teachers man
they're just getting it's just
ridiculous out there anyway but um
well they're showing that video of that
Library I started crying I had to walk
out Dave I walked out because I was
crying like it came over and it's just
like because that library is where I
learned to read I came out of the first
grade in the second grade not knowing
how to read
and my second grade teacher bless her
heart didn't know how to teach and that
she she worked one year in those
hillbilly kids drove her out of the
business and so but um then the soccer
in the third grade reading on a first
grade level and Miss Mary Jane hurt
taught me to read and by the time I go
out of the fourth grade level uh the
fourth grade I'm reading on sixth grade
level so that little library and I've
got I've had seven number one
best-selling books sold 25 million books
that I wrote okay that doesn't happen
unless you read
a lot yeah that goes with the territory
so learning is a good thing learning is
a good thing so you know I I love guys
like your husband though Sierra I I
almost could get on his side on this
except he's wrong he's wrong
[Laughter]
thanks for the call